Facebook is promising to work with
congressional investigators looking at
the Russian interference in the 2016
presidential election CEO Mark
Zuckerberg says the company will give
Congress thousands of political ads
likely brought by Russian based
operatives he also laid out new steps
that Facebook will take to prevent
foreign interference
Jeffrey gazes in Washington with that
story Jeff good morning good morning
Facebook had been under pressure to make
this move members of Congress here on
Capitol Hill had been pressing the
company to be more transparent on this
issue and yesterday in a sudden
about-face
Mark Zuckerberg announced that his
company wanted to do its part to ensure
a thorough investigation I care deeply
about the democratic process and
protecting its integrity in a live
address on Facebook founder Mark
Zuckerberg said the company will turn
over some 3,000 political ads if found
with links to Russia we support Congress
and deciding how to best use this
information to inform the public and we
expect the government to publish its
findings when their investigation is
complete
two weeks ago Facebook revealed that it
sold about a hundred thousand dollars
worth of ads dealing with political and
social issues used by Russian internet
trolls to spread disinformation but the
tech giant said most of the ads didn't
reference a particular candidate the
Senate Intelligence Committee has been
pressing the company for information as
it investigates Russian meddling in the
election Facebook took an important
first step in terms of saying they will
turn over to the committee what
information they've obtained we'll have
more questions for them earlier this
week Hillary Clinton addressed the issue
on The Late Show with Stephen Colbert I
don't think anybody can with a straight
face say that the Russians did not set
out to influence our election and they
did so this latest revelation about the
way they bought ads on Facebook and
targeted them we're gonna find out a lot
more Stephen Facebook also announced
nine steps to increase transparency
among them making it easier for people
to know who has paid for political ads
and we can't prevent all governments
from
all interference but we can make it
harder we can make it much harder and
that's what we're going to focus on
doing congressional investigators have
been weighing calling social media
executives to testify here on Capitol
Hill next month with growing evidence
that Russian trolls were able to use
social media to influence Americans
during the 2016 election this morning
the Kremlin denied any involvement
bianna Jeff thank you